the dynamism of the emerging private
space industry with its eye-popping
aircraft designs and new approaches to
launch is rejuvenating excitement around
space trouble once monopolized by a
budget-busting federal bureaucracy the
new leaders in space are wealthy
philanthropists with boyhood dreams of
space flight as well as entrepreneurs
who believe they can make money selling
tickets to the edge of space admittedly
when reason first declared the dawn of
private ventures in space we were off by
a number of years but in the last decade
tech billionaire such as Elon Musk
Richard Branson and Jeff Bezos have been
working through costly failures and
lengthy experiments to arrive at
workable approaches to a commercial
service in 2019 investors poured a
record 5.8 billion dollars into hundreds
of space ventures unless you take big
risks you'll not invent anything new you
not have breakthrough a pioneer in
private space travel Burt Rutan is a
renegade aerospace engineer whose
unconventional risk-taking designs
redefined what a spacecraft could look
like Rutan who was the winner of Reason
Foundation's 2019 Savas prize for
privatization design spaceship one the
first reusable manned crash to reach
space not underwritten by the government
how many aircraft have you designed and
built ok I've designed 391 now I built
and flight tested 49 five over Tanz
aircraft now hang in the National Air
and Space Museum
including Voyager the first aircraft to
fly non-stop around the world and
spaceship one I remember watching that
initial flight and also thinking even as
a layman thinking that aircraft looks
bunkers the only thing that's done for
for beauty is the paint trim everything
about spaceship one its shape that looks
bunkers there's a reason for that the
reason that it looks like a bullet is
it's a very lightest structure that you
can pressurize without having bending
moments and and stress concentrations
and so on you can't put big windows on
it without taking big risks so I put a
lot of little windows on it and I double
paned them every everything about it
particularly its feathered re-entry is
there
for a reason to not only allow it to be
done with a tiny budget for Paul Allen
but to make it possible
really Allen the Microsoft co-founder
and private space enthusiasts partnered
with Ratan and their team went on to win
the Ansari XPrize becoming the first
non-governmental organization to
successfully launch a reusable manned
spacecraft you know the government
didn't develop an airliner the
government didn't run an airline
business but the government has always
developed manned spacecraft and always
flown them you know there's just an a
was an assumption that since this is so
horribly expensive that it has to be
done by a huge outlays in the taxpayer
when I said I think I can do this Paul
Allen realized this was a huge risk but
he had the vision of saying well you
know returns not asking for much money
here when you're worth twenty six
billion not much money can still be
quite a lot of money 18 million isn't
much sir you've talked about though that
we should probably have I hope this is a
fair characterization a higher tolerance
for risk than we do now in space well if
you don't take risks you're not going to
have breakthroughs these Osen musk even
though the industry the world all the
primes all the government's had
concluded that's impossible to reuse
rocket boosters okay
they took enormous risks and tried
anyway and you know they all crashed at
first and kept crashing but well they
figured it out and now by reusing rocket
boosters it changes the the entire
outlook on our most going to happen for
the public as far as flying in space
reusable rockets and similar
advancements are largely being
bankrolled by a cadre of billionaire
philanthropists do you think it's fair
to say that the fact that we have
billionaires is why we have a private
space industry it's why we have a lot of
things there's nothing wrong with with
folk making huge amounts of money for
example wood wood we have an oil
industry if it wasn't for someone they
got very rich would we have had that
we'd be a third world country in terms
of energy if it were up to the
government and the taxpayer voting to
fund it with their taxes so I don't feel
embarrassed that the first decade or two
of space tourism is just something for
billionaires to have as a toy or as a
fun that's all right
you know we'll figure out what they're
for later on our freedoms in this
country are enormous compared to any
other country what country could use
could you with your own money fly your
tests or roadster beyond Mars
you know that's weird who would have
thought that that we'd ever see that
NASA wouldn't fund that yeah that
couldn't be done in Russia that was done
because of the freedoms in America it's
all right for a guy to make horrendous
profits you know why look what they do
with them they not just create jobs but
they create the future the lawn Musca
said that what he's doing on rocketry is
a hundred times more important than
curing cancer is he right well if you
cure cancer you save what 14% of us if
you can colonize another planet and
humans can learn to survive there you
could save all of us
[Music]
you